well it's a story we have been following
since 2013 when a local young girl named
Brazil Ward was hit by a car on
Halloween night that driver has never
been found thanks for joining us I'm
Denise Valdez well now nine years later
she and her family share how they've
turned tragedy into purpose Madison
Kimbrough joins us now live from where
that hit and run occurred with the story
it was here in this neighborhood that
the warts family's lives changed Forever
This created a massive wave of unity
that they are now extremely proud of
this was Brazil Ward when 8 news now
caught up with her several years ago and
this is Brazil now a 15 year old
teenager for those that don't know her
story Brazil is a Survivor and that's
not just because that's her Halloween
costume this year in 2013 a six-year-old
Brazil survived a hit-and-run crash
Halloween night leaving her with a
traumatic brain injury and in a coma for
months she truly is a living Miracle her
mother Tiffany Ward right by her side
remembering what it was like that
frightful night as we were crossing the
street a car going about 80 miles an
hour
sped down the street and we all really
had to jump out of the way but
unfortunately Brazil was caught in that
Crossfire of of trying to get out of the
way and she was struck and she was
thrown about 100 feet into the air the
whole Las Vegas Community following
Brazil's story ever since now nine years
later she and her family continue to
spread awareness of pedestrian safety be
safe
look both ways we're going to always
keep fighting to make sure that what
happened to our family doesn't happen to
other families we want to be able to
curve that so we at we partnered with
zero team fatalities we have a
non-profit called dreamsafe project and
we we spread pedestrian crosswalk safety
awareness and Brazil's younger sister
Berlin who was in a stroller when Brazil
was hit told us what this day means to
her it means a lot to me because
I'm happy that she's here with us
because if she wasn't I was only one so
I would even be able to remember her
while the hit and run driver was never
caught the Ward's hope is that their
constant presence in the community will
eventually bring Justice reporting live
in Spring Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now